your transformations are triggered by
anger and fear
those are like the baseline of any woman
just existing what's up everybody carlos
here marvel just gave us our first big
trailer for the new disney plus series
she-hulk attorney at law and it's safe
to say it has been smashing expectations
across the internet today so let's get
into it can you tell us where she-hulk
is jen you're a story now after a brief
narration by a familiar voice which
we'll get to in a minute we mean
jennifer walters an attorney who has to
deal with not only the pressures of
modern life and a highly stressful job
but a particular let's say affliction
that seems to run in the family
oh
yes yes yes
no no
that family is jennifer's cousin bruce
banner otherwise known as the incredible
hulk now in the comics jennifer gets her
powers after receiving an emergency
blood transfusion from bruce could this
car accident in the opening shots of the
trailer be the event that sets
everything in motion for she-hulk
canada's own tatiana maslany is making
her eagerly anticipated mcu debut in
this series most widely known for her
star turn in the hit sci-fi show orphan
black where she played multiple main
characters one of her co-stars is
already a big fan of her monstrous
acting talent
it's actually jaw-dropping just on a
day-to-day level you know that sometimes
the dialogue lands
you know just on that level
it lands in the morning
her ability to absorb
and then perform um was uh was quite
remarkable and she's funny one of the um
signs of a good actor is is their
ability to
uh
is there is their comedic touch and she
has it has it in space
yep that's tim roth who returns as emil
blonsky aka abomination tim first played
the character in the incredible hulk
back in 2008 and he will no doubt be a
major headache for jennifer in her role
as superhuman lawyer and possibly
superhero you could be an avenger oh i'm
not a superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason the
trailer shows that the series is clearly
comedic but that's not to say there
won't be a lot of action with several
marvel villains and heroes making
appearances in the trailer including the
aforementioned abomination the
surprising addition of wannabe hero
frogman and jamila jamil as she hulk
rival to tanya go toe-to-toe against
jennifer in a very different kind of
portland battle
i just want to be a normal anonymous
lawyer fan reaction has been very
positive so far and although there are
some folks questioning the quality of
the cg in the trailer most people are
excited for the series with some folks
waiting to see what other marvel lawyers
daredevil
could make an appearance and even more
folks interested in she hulk's love life
oh should we split some fries
let's get those to go
so what about you how excited are you
about she-hulk's mcu debut this august
let's talk about it in the comments
below and i'll see you next time
[Music]